ban
First, stir-fry the minced pork over high heat. Add the
firm tofu for about 2 minutes and drain. When the
color changes and it becomes fragrant and crispy, it's time to get involved.
It's not enough to add garlic and chili peppers It
was
n't like this because I ate it in Greater China
Watching the show,
but it's still not enough It's still
good to lose
Oh oh oh
Power On your lips
[music]
yeah I don't mind stealing, so
next time try another Chinese menu
For some reason, it's
just spicy.
Greater China 6 Mapo tofu has a
definite sweetness that's been
kneaded within
the spiciness.  And at that time,
even the oyster sauce was all specially made by his senior.
It's like a
dish where you can see the faces of both houses.